oh my
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today we're going to be trying out a new
format and instead of looking
to youtube for your daily dose of
wellness bs i'll be turning to
some of the nutrition memes and
infographics a lot of you have dm'd me
about on instagram so i'll be breaking
down these claims
one by one to sift out which ones
contain
truth to them and which ones are just
plain
bs due to the fact that instagram and
almost all social media platforms
have become so over saturated with
wellness tricks diet tips and
pseudoscience
it can be really hard to tell what
pieces of nutrition advice
are even remotely legit so i totally get
why so many of you
slid into my dms but before we get into
that nitty-gritty
a few standard disclaimers the
information
in this video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
and you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
two a quick trigger warning that some
graphics and discussions
may be disturbing to some of my viewers
so you can always feel free
to skip this video and finally don't
forget to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss
out all right now i'm not gonna lie
doing the research for this video was
both hilarious and infuriating
so we're gonna look at four different
photos that i found on the app from
various accounts
all containing nutrition facts and
discuss the scientific evidence behind
them
or more likely the lack thereof let's
start with
exhibit a yeah
things are about to get really
ridiculous um
this infographic about oranges was
actually
a part of an equally bogus series that
deserves
a whole hour-long video in itself
but as an example this slide claims that
oranges should be enjoyed as a snack as
they
improve digestion and increase
metabolism
yeah but they should be avoided at
breakfast as
eating oranges on an empty stomach can
cause irritation
and gastritis all right
let's start with the digestion and
metabolism claims about snacking on
oranges
first of all i will begin by clarifying
that oranges
do not inherently improve digestion more
so than
any other high fiber fruit i mean
there's nothing
magical about oranges specifically
but fiber on the other hand is magic
no just kidding um it just helps you
poop while also adding satiety to your
meals
and a medium orange has about four grams
so
in my books that's pretty great now
second if you're an avid abby's kitchen
fan you probably already know what i'm
going to say about
eating oranges to increase metabolism
aka
they don't similar to the infamous
claims about
lemon water oranges or really any other
fruit
cannot inherently make you burn more
calories on their own
so theories behind the citrus or citrus
and water for metabolism
obsession suggests that vitamin c
assists in fat burning at the cellular
level
due to the metabolic processes of
transporting fatty acids
within the cell since fatty acids
require vitamin c
as a cofactor to become an energy source
i know that was a lot to digest
get it but simply put vitamin c will
theoretically
help you burn fat however
these theories are simply that a theory
and kind of a crappy one at that with no
real scientific evidence
to back them up even if this theory has
any truth to it the amount of vitamin c
that you would hypothetically need to
consume to see
any measurable difference would be
pretty excessive
now although i can't tell you the exact
amount since we have no actual research
on this outside of a petri dish
with an isolated micronutrient it would
certainly be more than a couple of
slices of citrus fruit
in a glass of water or an orange as a
snack
now let's move on to the assumption that
eating oranges on an
empty stomach causes stomach irritation
and gastritis so that you should
apparently
avoid them in the morning now since
citrus fruits are higher in
acid than other fruits they may increase
acid production on an empty stomach
resulting in gerd aka acid reflux
and therefore gastritis aka the
inflammation of the stomach lining
this isn't something that really bothers
most people
but if you are prone to gerd or
heartburn you might
be more sensitive to acidic foods
but this is something that theoretically
could affect someone who's susceptible
any time of day and not just at
breakfast
and also for the general healthy
population this could be
a completely moot point so in conclusion
eat a damn orange whenever the heck that
you want
breakfast dinner snack dessert etc
unless you are predisposed to certain
digestive conditions
that may make you particularly sensitive
to eating
acidic foods on an empty stomach there's
really
no need to limit when or how often
oranges are enjoyed
next oh god you already know by the
title that this one
really tests my patience all right
so the instructions in this photo
suggest that you mix one cup of water
with one and a half tablespoons of
fennel
boil and strain it add some honey and
lemon of course
and consume it in the morning for a flat
belly yes dear because that
is the magic potion y'all probably know
i'm not a huge fan of these detox tonics
not to mention how society's obsession
with bloating has
recently become code for how to lose
weight
let's break down these ingredients one
by one and discuss some of the science
behind this
mystical drink first water
and staying hydrated in general is a
useful tip for preventing and managing
fluid retention
which of course can cause the feeling
and appearance of an abdominal bloat
well everyone's fluid needs are unique
and you should
always listen to your thirst cues
general hydration guidelines suggest
aiming for between two to three liters a
day
now second let's discuss fennel which
actually
does have some potential benefits so
fennelty
made by steeping fennel seeds in water
aka basically all this
revolutionary drink really is has some
weak evidence to suggest that it may
help reduce indigestion
bloating diarrhea and constipation but
the research that we have
is on concentrated oil not on steeped
tea so you'd likely need to drink a lot
of it to see any kind of measurable
impact third while honey is
full of health benefits there really
isn't a lot of research linking honey to
having any particular effects on
digestion
other than its potential to act as a
mild prebiotic
so let's just all assume that this
recipe includes honey
largely to make the drink taste a little
bit less like the contents of your
unorganized
stale spice drawer and finally
let's go back to instagram's go-to
wellness ingredient
lemon so again lemons are an excellent
source of vitamins like vitamin c
but they are not the weight loss panacea
the working hypothesis is that it acts
as a natural diuretic when added to warm
water
so that drinking lemon water can help to
reduce the amount of salt that you
retain from food
and therefore relieve bloating but
i must say it one more time for the
people in the back
lemon water does not possess the power
to
detox you or give you a flat
belly the evidence just does not
stack up so in summary
the only potential truth in this
infographic is that staying
hydrated can help you to avoid fluid
retention
and that fennel seeds may have some mild
digestion promoting benefits
however that does not make this drink a
remedy for a flat belly
it is simply a tea that can help you
with your digestion
particularly if you are having stomach
issues or are in need of some hydration
you're not going down a pant size after
having a morning cup
in fact there's no particular reason to
drink this tea
in the morning either if anything
fennel is actually traditionally
consumed after a meal
to aid with digestion not before on an
empty stomach
and before i get off my anti-detox
soapbox here can we please just
normalize human bellies and their
tendency to expand and contract
throughout the day obviously painful
bloating that is truly uncomfortable
might be a sign that something else is
going on however
having your stomach be a little more
distended after a meal
or during your period or when you've
just had like a salty meal
is 100 percent normal
and we need to start normalizing regular
bodily functions
that diet culture has taught us to be
ashamed of
okay bye all right on to the next
nutrition meme this one contains
a lot of detailed information about food
and digestion times that i guess we're
gonna have to break down
one by one
lord give me strength so
according to this photo fruit takes 20
to 40 minutes to digest
veggies take 30 to 60 minutes grains
take 90 to 120 minutes
and nuts and seeds can take like two to
three
hours the graphic also advises us to eat
quickly digested foods at breakfast and
dinner so it doesn't put unnecessary
strain on the body
when you wake up or when you go to sleep
and then to eat foods with a
mixture of digestion times at lunch when
your body is
most productive oh boy
we could spend hours here talking about
all of the things that affect the rate
at which we digest food
however i'm going to just try to narrow
down to three food component factors
fiber fat and protein otherwise known to
me and my homies
as the hunger crushing combo now it's
generally accepted in the world of
nutrition that carbohydrates
are digested the fastest and then
proteins
and fats take the longest however there
are numerous
aspects to food that can affect the rate
at which we digest them
not to mention no food contains only
one of these components but for
argument's sake
first let's talk fiber now we've
actually got
two types of fiber soluble fiber which
helps you feel
full because it slows down the digestion
of food
and then insoluble fiber which gets food
moving through the digestive tract
which can improve regularity now second
we've got protein
which is comprised of strings of amino
acids which need to be broken apart in
order to be
absorbed and that does take some time
so there is a bit more work involved to
get the job done
and then last we've got fats most of the
digestion of fats occurs in the small
intestine
so they are a slow moving macronutrient
that takes your body a good amount of
work to break down
and therefore are very saturating to eat
so knowing this hierarchy of
macronutrients and digestion
we can make some inferences when it
comes to the relative
transit times of certain kinds of foods
so
meat and fish for example have protein
and fat but
no fiber so they take generally the
lungs to digest
fruit and veggies often have fiber but
in varying amounts
and in the case of something like
avocado also may have
fats the speed of their digestion
also really depends on how it's prepared
so cooked or blended kale will be
digested
much faster than raw whole kale because
these
processing techniques help to pre-digest
or break the fibers down the digestion
of starches and
other carbs will also depend on the
fiber
where things like candy will be digested
and absorbed almost immediately
but something like oatmeal or bran will
take
longer because of the extra fiber so we
really can't make blanket statements
about
how fast food groups are digested
since this will really depend on the
specific food
how it's prepared and also the gut
and metabolism of the individual who is
consuming it
now that we've discussed the alleged
digestive times of certain foods
let's tackle the whole breakfast versus
lunch versus dinner debate
when it comes to eating specific kinds
of foods
now the most genuine piece of
information here is that some people
might find that eating too close to bed
may exacerbate digestive symptoms like
acid reflux
or gerd now research suggests that a
shorter dinner to bed time
is associated with increased reflux
likely because
you're simply not allowing gravity
enough time
to help keep digestive juices in your
stomach
before you lie down and the result of
that
for some people can be acid reflux
now for everybody else who aren't
necessarily impacted by night eating
there is actually also evidence to
suggest that your basal
metabolic rate while sleeping is
virtually
the same as it is when you're awake so
in other words if the old diet culture
rhetoric about
stop eating after six has any truth to
it at all
it's not because your metabolism just
immediately shuts down when the clock
strikes
a certain time your body isn't
cinderella
but rather it's because cutting yourself
off
with some arbitrary rule means less food
is generally consumed it's also
important to note that you aren't
necessarily putting stress on your body
by consuming slower digesting foods in
the morning
and these foods certainly do not need to
be limited to just
lunch and finally the whole lunch is the
best time to eat foods of various
digestion times
is total food combining garbage your
body is
super sophisticated and can employ the
right enzymes
all at the same time to do their job
simultaneously
you don't have to worry about creating a
traffic jam
in your gut but you already know i've
already smashed that myth both here
and here so to summarize this hot mess
of the photo
there is truth to the fact that various
foods take differing amounts of time to
digest
and it can be useful to keep this
information in mind
for certain scenarios so for example
what you might want to eat before a hit
cardio workout to get fast energy
might be different than what you might
want to eat before a long meeting
that you know you can't escape from to
have a snack
having said that digestive transit times
are a
highly individualized and complex
process
and every body uses a whole host of
different factors
to determine how long it will take to
digest that food
also while we already discussed food and
digestion
we did not even begin to consider the
different phases of digestion
and how long it takes each individual
phase to occur
so from the mouth to esophagus esophagus
to stomach
stomach to small intestine small
intestine to large intestine
large intestine too well your toilet
bowl etc
similar to the food combining mist that
we've already discussed on my channel
infographics like these undermine the
fact that the human body
is a highly efficient and evolved system
designed to break down food from a
variety of sources
excluding any medical reasons to alter
your diet in a certain way
rules like these ones regarding when to
eat certain foods
are arbitrary self-imposed and quite
frankly
total bs next
all right finally let's round things off
by exploring a meme that has
a little more scientific truth to it
well
kinda so this image suggests that
drinking water from a copper cup
offers a variety of benefits such as
killing bacteria
stimulating the brain regulating thyroid
function
soothing arthritis pain boosting skin
health
slowing down aging improving digestion
getting rid of anemia and lowering the
risk of cancer
and heart disease that was a lot
now this like most nutrition information
disseminated by people who don't really
understand how to communicate
research in the real world is based on a
shred of science in a vacuum and then
wrongfully extrapolated
to real life there's a lot of ground to
cover here
let's take a look at each claim one
by one first that copper kills bacteria
so research has found that copper oxide
nanoparticles
do have some antibacterial activity
against human pathogens like e coli
and staphylococcus bacterial strains but
this says absolutely nothing about their
transference
from a cup second is that copper
stimulates the brain
so copper has been found to be an
important mineral for the enzymes that
activate the brain's neurotransmitters
in response to various stimuli but i
would say that
stimulates the brain is pretty vague
and also kind of misleading it's
technically true
in an indirect biochemical way but
there's
absolutely no evidence that you'll get
smarter
or more alert from drinking water out of
a specific cup
third is that copper regulates thyroid
function
so adequate copper levels are correlated
to adequate thyroid hormones in the body
now one study actually found that
patients who were diagnosed with
hypothyroidism
were also found to typically have
significantly
lower concentrations of certain trace
minerals including
copper but this is correlation not
causation
and we don't know the impact on
hypothyroid management
of getting more copper from one's diet
or from a cup
now fourth is that copper soothes
arthritis pain
this fact is usually analyzed by
evaluating the effectiveness
of wearing a copper bracelet as opposed
to actually ingesting
dietary copper however one study
investigating the effects of copper on
soothing arthritis pain
found no difference between the group
wearing a copper bracelet
and the placebo group so i'm calling bs
on that fifth is that copper improves
skin health now copper does play a role
in the development of new blood vessels
skin generation and the stabilization of
extracellular skin proteins
and there is some early evidence to
suggest that copper containing
pillowcases
may help to reduce age-related skin
aging
but that doesn't tell us anything about
ingesting copper
especially through a medium like water
in a copper
cup and six is that it slows
age-related diseases okay so
while inadequate copper levels in the
body has been linked to an increased
risk of age-related diseases
like cardiovascular disease copd kidney
disease and alzheimer's
the same can be said about most
nutrients
hence why we need enough of all of the
major micro and macronutrients
to thrive but we also know that the
research
does not suggest that getting more
copper through supplementation
will significantly reduce the risk of
any of these diseases
now seventh is that copper improves
digestion
now i searched even the shadiest
research databases
and the only logical link that i could
make between
copper and digestion is that due to
copper's antibacterial properties
it may lead one to consume fewer
pathogens
but yeah it's not going to make you
bloat less
or temper your gas then eighth is that
copper reduces anemia
so clinical copper deficiency while rare
can actually present like symptoms of
anemia
including fatigue and a weakened immune
system
copper is also an essential nutrient for
absorbing iron from the gut
when copper levels are low the body
absorbs
less iron which subsequently can result
in anemia
so i suppose if we're talking about the
difference between
hardcore deficiency and adequate levels
yes getting adequate copper may help to
reduce
some symptoms of anemia but again
getting more isn't likely of any benefit
then nine copper reduces the risk of
cancer
so inadequate consumption of dietary
copper has been linked to lower fecal
free radical production
fecal water cytotoxicity and alkaline
phosphatase activity all of which are
risk factors for colon cancer
but again this is at extreme deficiency
stages
and are impact factors that increase the
risk factors for cancer
not increase cancer per se
and lastly congratulations if you've
made it to number 10
copper's impact on heart health
now the heart is one of the main organs
affected by
copper deficiency which can cause a
reduction in metabolism
and energy supply to the heart both of
these consequences can put a person at
higher risk
of heart disease but as i already
mentioned
while we may have observational research
linking low copper levels
to higher risk of heart disease we have
little evidence to suggest that
supplementation
in healthy individuals actually helps
so to summarize these claims with a few
overarching
takeaways about research in general
first
almost all of the evidence i just cited
is weak evidence that drinking water out
of a copper cup
does anything at all these claims are
largely based on some of the known
biochemical roles of copper in the body
or in a petri dish and not on any
evidence that's supplementing with it
never mind somehow kind of getting it
out of a medium
like water that touches a copper cup
makes
any clinical significant difference and
if it does
that difference would likely only be
seen for people who are
actually severely deficient but copper
deficiency is
really uncommon in humans because copper
is
readily accessible through the diet in
foods like shellfish and fish
nuts and seeds organ meats wheat bran
cereals
whole grain products and dark chocolate
groups who are
more at risk of copper deficiency
include people with celiac disease due
to
malabsorption people taking really high
doses of
zinc supplements which can interfere
with copper absorption
as well as people who are suffering from
menkin's disease
which is a very rare condition
if you are healthy and consuming a
generally well-balanced diet
you're probably meeting your copper
needs
if not is drinking from a copper cup
even a good way to get
dietary copper maybe it's
really hard to know studies have shown
that copper
is able to leach into water via copper
pipes
fixtures and alloys in water
distribution systems
as well as in household plumbing so it
is likely that it can also
do so through a cup as well how much
we don't really know so then the
question is
is it dangerous to drink your water out
of a copper cup
meh probably not while chronic exposure
to high levels of copper
can result in liver damage and gi
symptoms like abdominal pain
cramps nausea vomiting and diarrhea
copper toxicity is quite rare for the
average person who
doesn't have a hereditary copper
homeostasis defect like wilson's disease
so drink out of a copper cup because it
looks badass in hipster
and moscow mules are one of the best
adult bevies
but unless you are legit deficient it's
not likely going to make
any kind of clinically significant
difference in
any of these proposed areas of health i
think if you can take
anything away from this video it's to
highlight how
inadequate a meme is at explaining the
complexities of nutrition research
not to mention that a lot of what you
see on instagram
is just plain false and created by
people who
probably know very little to nothing
about nutrition
or how to interpret nutrition research
let's
also remember that just because you read
something on the internet that has
supposedly worked for somebody else
and their body or in the case of a lot
of these beams
worked in a vacuum or petri dish it does
not necessarily mean it's going to work
for you
in your unique environment and body i'm
not saying
everything online is bs but make sure
you're accessing information from a
reputable source
if you plan to take any ounce of it as
truth
and that is all for today folks let me
know if you guys
like this nutrition meme video by giving
it the thumbs up
also let me know below if you want to
see more of them
there is sure as hell a lot more where
that came from so
if you're on instagram make sure that
you're following me at abby's kitchen
and feel free to slide into my dms with
whatever
bunkery you come across on your feed
finally don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
and ring that little bell so you don't
miss out and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye